let's try alex from baltimore alex
you're on the air hi david can you hear
me
yes i can alright hey how you doing
i um i'd like to actually have a
question about
history and how other as you know
well-traveled person as you are
how other cultures see their history
okay because
at least on more left-leaning people in
the united states
they read about american history and a
lot of it is shameful
but and then they personally become game
that
they say they're ashamed to be an
american in this country is nothing but
evil and racist i was just curious how
do like
european people feel about such things
because they certainly have a bad
history of
colonialism and atrocities to native
people
are you aware of anything like that um i
don't
i mean listen so i know europeans from
the uk from spain from
france from italy which has less of a
colonial history
from belgium which has quite a colonial
history you know so on and so forth
germany you know i what i can tell you
is
all the germans i know feel really bad
about the history of nazism and they
sort of go
out of their way to distance and to talk
about how they
completely denounce it when it comes to
places like uk
france spain which also have and and
belgium which have colonial histories
it's just never been a topic of
conversation it's a great question how
much of their identity
in their country uh as as a you know
someone from their country
is tied up in the colonial history it's
never come up and i don't know what that
tells us but
i you'd have to really ask them that's
fair
i just i i'm just kind of in the middle
of those two um i still consider myself
to be proud to be an american because
there's a lot of good things but i don't
figure code the terrible things we've
done
either just yeah for me it's like
as a naturalized american i don't really
use the term proud one way or the other
i don't say i'm proud or that i'm
that there's an absence of i i just
think about it more like
you know my family moved here because
the economic situation was terrible in
argentina
and it's not a thing of pride but i'm
aware
that at the time there was an economic
opportunity here that didn't exist in
argentina
and i believe as an individual i've
benefited
drastically from growing up in the u.s
rather than argentina like i'm without
question
i'm financially orders of magnitude
better off
because of that does that make me it's
not about proud it's i recognize the
opportunity that i got
and i'm glad for it you know does that
make sense that's
that's totally fair i guess i could fall
in that myself that makes a lot of sense
i do have a quick silly um
food uh debate question for you please
um i'm gonna ask you
do you prefer coffee or tea but
the whichever one you pick the other one
is completely vaporized off the face of
the earth
okay never drink it again
yeah i mean i i prefer coffee i guess if
tea were vaporized i'd have lemonade
i don't know that's fair yeah i always
said i prefer
tea if it had the same caffeine content
as coffee but that's just me
okay all right very good well i'm glad
we were able to sort that out
yes thank you all right have a great day
first question was
excellent excellent excellent first
question let's focus on the positive
there please my friends
uh okay thank you to everybody who
called i'm sorry
i'm sorry i can't get to more people
today but we do have a time limit
and we will take calls again very very
soon